I'm Mike I'm gonna talk to you today
about my art practice as a game designer
using Java scripts to make games and
other installation art too we're
hardware and other electronics
specifically we're talking about this
hardware which is a Western Electric
five five one a PBX switchboard from
1927 now I'm sure all of you are
intimately familiar with Western
electrics five five one line but in case
you've forgotten the five five one a was
the smallest they made the be the next
one up is literally three of these next
to each other that to people would have
used this one would have been used in a
hotel or a small office this actual
literal specific switchboard was used at
the mead paper mill in Chillicothe Ohio
where there's some stickers on it that
suggests what show a coffee thank you
Chillicothe Ohio where there's some
stickers suggesting it was used through
the 60s so probably over 40 years which
is pretty ridiculous especially
considering it was likely the same
literal person doing that job all 40
years you can't really see here but we
have the original name labels on there
that I've names like Smith and Jones and
the front lobby and the beer man there's
a whole fascinating history there that
we're not really going to talk about
we're gonna talk about its present
instead which is this game called hello
operator so as a game designer I make
experiences that use non-traditional
interfaces that connect people to the
world around them sort of hope to teach
some things about the systems that world
our world and so this was part of my
research at the MIT Media Lab for this
game you sit down and you use it as if
it was your day job actually learning
how to use this hardware to connect to
people who want to make phone calls to
each other there's obviously a bunch of
concessions that had to be made to like
make it a fun game but for the most part
the goal here was actual authenticity
you can learn the game by going through
the interactive tutorial it has or you
could actually read the instruction
manual that came with it in the 20s and
it's close enough that that would teach
you how to play the game but for the
most part it's what's known as a time
management game maybe some of you might
know the early 80s arcade game tapper or
casual games from 10 or 20 years ago
called diner - that are all about you
are some sort of sort of service worker
helping people out and you have this
sequence of steps to help a single
customer like in my case someone's late
turns on because they want to make a
phone call you connect them you pick up
the phone they tell you they want to
talk to you you connect them to that
person etc this chain of events is very
simple but when 10 people want to make
calls at once it gets very hectic very
quickly and you have to manage your time
pretty well so we'll touch a bit more
later on sort of why and why I think is
interesting and why pick the time to do
stuff like this but for the most part
I'm going to touch on two different
things in this talk the first part is
going to be the actual process of
working with physical hardware like as
someone who's done some hardware but is
mostly a software person what do you do
when 150 pounds of hundred-year-old
Hardware shows up on your doorstep and
then after that we'll talk a bit about
software and sort of cross-platform
stack that let me actually develop this
and sort of design a design process for
making these digital physical hybrid
games both with hollow operator and some
other projects I've worked on so yeah
you just bought a switch board on eBay
and had it shipped halfway across the US
what do you do now you probably want to
open it up and see what's inside
which was the first problem we had so
the back of the switch board came off
really easily there was this handle you
can see that front there there are
cables there are lights there are some
switches you also might be able to see a
keyhole on the front there that surprise
was locked we talked to the guy who sold
it to us he had no idea we brought in
some people who are handy with a
lockpick set because it was MIT you
there are a lot of those no one could
get in we went on eBay and bought some
random other keys for switchboards that
looked kind of similar unsurprisingly
none of them worked so I ended up like
it pained me but I had to cut through
this cheap piece of sheet metal on the
bottom we could unscrew and where the
sheet metal we could remove the lock and
that could have been it like it was a
little annoying having the front
flapping up and down and when we tried
to move it but one of my colleagues John
did probably the coolest single part of
this whole project was he looked at this
lock and said this looks really simple I
can do something with this and grabs a
set of calipers that's a measuring did a
little bit of 3d modeling made a couple
test prints on our 3d printer downstairs
and long story short this is the 3d
printed metal key that fits our 1920s
lock
[Applause]
and like we still actually use this a
lot whiskey today when when traveling
with it but to even then you open it up
and you see this weird mass of wires but
not wires that make sense so if you take
a step back and look at that front table
area of the switchboard conceptually
there are a bunch of different columns
where a column has two cables two lights
two switches conceptually those are
linked so if you have two cables that
are plugged into two different sort of
ports representing telephones and you
flipped things are correctly that means
those two people are talking to each
other and within that via there sort of
a front/rear connection so the frontmost
cable and a column connects to the
frontmost light connects to the front
most switch the front these switches are
like you might call them single-pole
double-throw if you've worked with
hardware switches before but not really
as we'll get to in a second so
conceptually they start out neutral in
the middle you can move them away from
you or towards you if you move them away
from you they stay in place that means
you are talking to the person who is
connected to you as the operator if you
pull them towards you through momentary
so you let it go and it snaps back and
that means you are ringing that person
like that physical phone at the other
end of that cable is ringing so if
you're doing this in modern electronics
like there are a couple pins coming out
of it that's relatively straightforward
this is what it looked like there are
seven pins well each switch has two pin
blocks that turned out to be mirrored
each of those pin blocks had seven pins
coming out of them each of those pins
had probably four or five cables coming
out of them and it turns out they
activated in really weird circumstances
like this pin is only going to cause a
connection to ground when you're
momentarily transitioning between like
the middle state and the talked state
and again if you've done anything with
hardware at a hobbyist level or
otherwise this is pretty weird but it
turns out like if it's the 1920s all of
the logic you have is based on relays it
probably makes sense if there's
something that you know you need to
happen in a specific space why not have
that logic happen at the level of metal
plates touching each other rather than
having to construct some giant set of
relays somewhere else and similarly if
you are
if you know that this signal is going to
be needed in a whole bunch of different
places rather than find some way to
multiplex it why not run multiple cables
to it which creates this weird
disconnect when trying to connect it to
a modern computer or even trying to make
sense of it like this was the the
documentation I was able to find from
service manuals in the 1920s even
electrical engineer your friends I
talked to like I have no idea what's
going on so the answer I wish I had a
better answer than the equivalent of
like debugging via print statement
so for these seven pins we grabbed some
alligator clips and wired them up to a
multimeter to the connectivity tester
which is just if these two things are
completing a circuit you will hear a
beep and this slow methodical process of
once we figured out which one ground was
take every other pin connect them flip
the switch figure out over time what
does each one of these pins do slow
methodical work the back was more of the
same I will point out what is super cool
you see those big red and white things
those aren't the cables those are the
individual lead weights that were on
each cable so that when you drop it in
place it immediately falls back exactly
where it should go super satisfying but
again we look at these like these ports
on the front they look like they should
just be like audio jacks like we're used
to but there is this incredibly
intimidating but amazing cable
management I've heard I have not
validated this but I've been told that
like we don't know how to do this style
of cable management anymore it's just
something we've forgotten how to do
there's these beautiful like pieces of
string tying these rows in place and
it's all meticulously oiled wire awesome
stuff but also these cables they look
like they look like quarter-inch audio
jacks they're actually called Bantam
which just it's slightly differently
physically shapes you can see three
contacts on that on that cable like two
data pins and a ground and yet there are
five pins coming out of the ports and
each of those again has a whole bunch of
cables coming out of them and some of
them are connecting to these pin blocks
on the side that were wired up in ways
that were really unintuitive so it was a
lot of manual trial and error figuring
out how is this actually wired up given
that I did really value I wanted to use
the original cabling where possible
wanted to not destroy as much as
possible sort of more out of
sentimentality that I mean practical
reason but it was great meaning that
here we could wire stuff up to these pin
blocks and actually have it work you can
also see some of the other places where
we are splicing into original wiring
with our own wire the other coolest part
of this Hardware the one last neat thing
to touch on on so all of those lights on
the front
those were tiny little incandescent
bulbs that has happened to be the shape
of LEDs and they were attached via these
hand-carved wooden sockets to be clear
this photo this is with a modern LED
this isn't one of the original
incandescent bulbs but what and like
this this led to some really frustrating
times because how can we not use these
but it meant that getting the LEDs wired
up is actually a pain so besides like
major props to my colleague Miguel who
is gracious enough to spend a couple
hours individually desoldering each of
those bulbs and replacing them with a
modern LED it's like it would have been
a major pain to get power to all the
light bulbs at like the way needed to
run if one of them burnt out we probably
would have needed to replace all of them
this was just easier but it led to these
other problems where like if you've done
if you've done any sort of modern
Hardware work with LEDs like often
you'll use these things called neopixels
or other similar daisy chain of all LEDs
so an old fashioned cheap LED has two
pins coming out of it if you have power
going in the right way and going out the
other way it'll light up hopefully you
have a resistor in there too
the problem with that is when you have a
lot of them like say a switchboard with
50 lights on top and 20 on the bottom
that means you need seven di opens which
is a lot of IO pens these days you can
buy these beautiful daisy chainable LEDs
that are multicolored and you can do
whatever you want with them and you can
connect basically an arbitrary amount
with a fixed number of data pins that is
far smaller than 70 but they require
three pins instead of two and we have
these beautiful hand-carved wooden
sockets that have two contacts in them
and even if you are willing to say like
alright it's fine we don't have to use
this stupid beautiful hand-carved wooden
sockets well that's how the LEDs get
attached to the switchboard now we'd
have to design our whole other
mechanism for locking these LEDs into
place and getting them wired up which
meant really just wanted to use the
actual sockets which meant we had to
deal with that many eye opens which was
part of a larger systemic problem but
again for anyone who has done the
electronics work you're probably used to
the idea that if you buy an Arduino off
the shelf
it's got like 14 IO pins and maybe you
think five analog ones that you can
maybe use is general purpose i/o I don't
know a Raspberry Pi has twenty-something
so we have potentially 70 LEDs we have
50 ports on top 20 cables 20 of these
switches that go two ways so we need
multiple pins for them and then we also
had a magnetic sensor so we could detect
when you pick up or put down the phone
and the rotary dial on the side that's a
lot like as someone who had done
hobbyist scale electronics with Arduino
I didn't know how to deal with I know
need hundreds of i/o pins one of my
colleagues at MIT gave me this like
industrial grade prototyping board that
I found a Windows machine I installed
the proprietary IDE and the hello world
example didn't compile so my next step
was looking at all right can i fabricate
my own chips like at the media lab the
fabrication strap has a lot of stuff I'd
done a bunch of that before we had an
atmel ship that had like 54 i/o pins but
everything in our fabrication shop was
you are designing a circuit board
yourself you are milling it down stairs
you are soldering the surface mount
components elf these are very very small
it takes a lot of practice to even deal
with the most basic service mount
components and this specific chip had
pads that were small enough that it was
very clearly not meant for a human to
solder by hands and I'd never used a
reflow station before so we then found
sometimes the lazy solution is the best
solution I went down to Micro Center
which is like that the local electronics
store and in Arduino mega which is like
the Arduino board that uses that exact
same Atmel chip knockoffs were ten bucks
each so we bought four of those and that
gave us like two hundred i/o pins which
was enough and I designed and fabricated
these little like Arduino shields for
him that wired up to all the i/o pins we
needed with quick cable disconnects so
it was super easy to swap them out of
one broke
that sort of thing and it was all
connected to a Mac Mini we had lying
around driving it the last sort of
electronics bit of trivia was figuring
out how to actually figure out what
cable was plugged into which port was a
real problem sort of the solution I
ended up on turns out to be something
you might be familiar with if you built
your own mechanical keyboard and build
out a key matrix so we had all of the
all of the ports were configured as
inputs wherever excite everything was
always high then you go through one of
them one by one and for each cable say
make it an output that's sending a low
value you can then read through every
input if any of them are low that means
you know that they're connected to each
other and so you can scan through your
update loop and you know alright we know
exactly which cables are plugged into
which ports that was really easy in like
a dozen lines of our do we know see in
the first version of this when we only
had the top two rows connected to each
other which meant that we only had 20
plus 20 is 40 which meant we had enough
pins that we could fit it on a single
Arduino board as opposed to the full 70
meant we now had disbanded across two
different Arduino boards and everything
was connected to a computer but going
through serial over USB and then talking
to a node process wasn't fast enough to
really do the like timing
synchronization in a way that would have
worked so we had to directly connect the
two Arduinos to each other which again
if you were someone who actually does
the sort of thing for a living this is
still relatively trivially easy but for
me it was sort of a slow process of
figuring out like oh this is all we have
to do once you notice everything I've
talked about is very specifically just
talking about hardware I have not said
anything about building software other
than some Arduino C or actually
designing a fun game which was very
intentional so that my goal was looking
at how can I tackle this hardware is its
own problem so we could let the design
space be its own problem which partly
that's how I like to work I've done this
on a bunch of projects but we also had a
very concrete problem here which this is
a this is a story of poor project
management that I don't recommend but so
this game started out as custom hardware
I built this for a fabrication class so
this is like custom waterjet steel that
was saying blasted and spray painted and
some CNC and stained wood and then we
submitted it to alt control GDC which is
the Game Developers Conference big
selection of games with weird
physical controls and once it was
accepted we knew we wanted to go out and
buy this hardware and do it right so
when it was accepted to GDC was about a
three month period from when the
switchboard showed up until we had to
mail it out was about three weeks and
then from there I had about two more
weeks I could work on it except I didn't
have access to the switchboard so all of
that Hardware stuff I just described was
about three weeks of work I do not
recommend that I do not want to glorify
crunch like there are questions about
whether I should have gotten into that
situation um but that meant that it was
super important that I needed to be able
to make a fun game without touching the
hardware because for most the
development cycle I hadn't even seen the
hardware yet so to me what is beautiful
about software compared to making with
almost anything else is you have this
instantaneous feedback cycle like me
fabricating a new board for the Arduino
shield would be a couple hours if I was
mailing him out it would take weeks
I used two unit tests completing in
anywhere between seconds to milliseconds
depending on what sort of stack it is so
to be thinking about this design process
was a process of for everything that I'm
doing what is the absolute tightest
feedback loop I can get and then how do
I design sort of like concentric circles
of feedback loops so that I can do
everything I need to as quickly as
possible for that thing so at the most
basic level there's this question of
I've written some code does it do what I
expected it to this often means tests
games are often pretty hard to test I
think a lot of reasons for that or
cultural but also a lot of it is just
the problem with testing content and
this is a giant like an early stateful
state machine that poking at it manually
is going to be easier than anything else
so it's important to me to both be able
to write unit tests but also very
quickly gets you like a command line and
have this sort of parser interactive
fiction style interface where I can play
the game without contact shifting you
can't really write a test to say is this
game fun yet you need manual play
testing the hard part about play testing
isn't the actual play testing it's
getting play testers and saying hey you
need to come to my research lab I can't
come to you all so it needs to be in
this three-week period that's a problem
so we knew early on I wanted a version
of the game
that could run on an iPad that seemed
like the perfect compromise of people
can understand a drag-and-drop
touchscreen controls I can fit it in my
bag and take it to play test events I
was already going to in Cambridge and
San Francisco like that seemed like the
right balance I don't have a good
screenshot of it because that no longer
compiles because it's an old version of
Swift you can sort of see it on top of
the switchboard there and then finally
like you can test is this game fun on an
iPad you can you can build a fun time
management game but a lot of stuff is
harder to test like the onboarding
experience it's very easy to handle I
pad to someone and say this gray
rectangle represents a table you can
drag it around when people sit down at
this actual Swiss border it is
incredibly intimidating and it takes
them a while to learn I can do things
that are incorrect and this scary game
isn't going to punish me I can I can use
this I can use this like plug in the
cables with force and this
hundred-year-old hardware is going to
outlive me I'm not going to destroy it
and those sorts of things can't really
be tested without the actual hardware
which also meant that given that the
hardware was in my physical hands for
such a short period of time and I didn't
know when I could get people there at
any given time I needed to be able to
deploy the current build of the game
onto the hardware without much fuss like
a big heavy deploy process would have
been a non-starter so I think most of
the people in this room are software
engineers you can start to see many
shapes to the answer of this problem
depending on what flavor of software you
do like in broad strokes this is a
problem where we want to separate like
this business logic engine of a game
from like how it is actually literally
playing so we have this little
JavaScript game that manages the state
machine and all that that just when you
instantiate it I pass in an object that
the game has this API contractor it
knows it can it can turn on Mabel's LED
and it doesn't care if turning on
Mabel's LED means a physical LED is
turned on or UI view is changing colors
or we're console logging something out
it just knows that that's going to work
which is great because it means we can
make the game run anywhere we can throw
on that fake adapter for tests or CLI
for one that's running in JavaScript
core on an iPad with some bindings out
to native Swift code that's creating a
view layer or
talking to the actual for Arduinos and
we can separate engine development from
hardware development in the way we want
to which again this probably sounds
straightforward to a lot of you
depending on where you're coming from
you talk about MVC or mvvm or solid
object or any design principles or like
react style view as a pure function of
state then unidirectional data flow but
that's not really how games or hardware
work like these are both sort of fields
of engineering that are coming out of
spaces of much more constrained
resources whether that is like literally
a microcontroller that has very limited
space for writing your program or a game
engine where you're running on limited
hardware and need to have a 3d engine
and physics and all these complex things
which means like if you're writing
microcontroller code you're probably
writing in the Arduino IDE and you have
a single function that runs on start and
then you have an update loop if you're
writing code in unity you are operating
inside unities monolithic framework if
this is how your game is structured and
so with these it's very difficult to say
I want to optimize for what is gonna
make me most productive whereas
conversely it's 2018 computers are
really cheap I was able to solve my
microcontroller problem with a bunch of
$10 Arduino knockoffs and a Mac Mini
that we had lying around but they cost
500 bucks and Intel nook is a couple
hundred our Raspberry Pi is 40 or PI 0
was 5 we honestly could have run this
game on a PI 0 but we didn't need to
because we had the Mac Mini like I think
a lot of it comes down to like if you're
a developer like a web developer looking
at a startup you're used to the idea
that our servers aren't scaling at some
point when you to bring someone in to
rewrite this code so it can actually
scale but for now we can throw more
money at Heroku or ec2 or whoever and
right now because we're constrained on
developer time like in the long run that
won't work but it'll work for now the
stur the same thing happened here like I
could have gotten hello operator running
on the arduino z' and done some clever
synchronization to actually add the game
logic execute on the micro controller
but why would I do that when I could run
it on this Mac Mini and lets me focus on
writing software that's optimized for
ease of debugging and playtesting rather
than anything else I get let me spend
time wearing my artist hat and my
designer hat
than like an electrical engineering hat
or an embedded systems hat Witcher greet
hats to wear apparently I have a giant
hat collection but being able to work in
this ecosystem that I knew helped as
well which is also where like everything
I talked about was JavaScript
specifically typescript so I thought for
me at the rate I was moving like that
type system was the right balance of
this is going to help me catch stupid
errors when writing tests doesn't make
sense but really anything that is
cross-platform is good enough like
javascript CC start Java anything that
you're comfortable with especially this
sort of really worked given that I'm not
making these traditional games these are
experiences where I don't need a physics
ends and I don't need a 3d render or
everything I am doing is is my of my own
design more or less which also ties into
like for me personally Java scripts
worked well but again any cross-platform
average worked because once you're
working in the same tooling across
multiple projects you can start to have
cross-pollination so all of this was my
side project while I was at MIT my main
project was working on location-based
storytelling and looking at how can we
use fiction to connect people to real
world spaces and so I had these
essentially interactive radio plays
where you'd go to a physical space don't
learn an app on your phone and as you
would walk around we'd sort of change
the story based on where you're walking
like do you take the left path or the
right path but also is it raining
are you there and the winter versus the
summer what are the things we can do
with the bundle of sensors in your
pocket so I built this sort of
interactive fiction narrative engine and
custom scripting language all in
JavaScript it was designed around so you
have this sort of linear or multi linear
narrative structure or dialogue tree how
can you modify that based off of
arbitrary data sensors instead of like
clicking on hyperlinks or making many
like dialog choices like a traditional
interactive fiction engine might so then
I had this problem the first time I
showed the switchboard I had to explain
how to play the game to everyone who
walked by and wanted to play it which if
you have ever shown any sort of
installation like this in a festival
setting you know the absolute most
important thing is to make sure that it
runs itself so the next time I showed it
I know I need an interactive tutorial
and it needed to be at the level of like
we're going to tell you what to do and
here's for the
took steps to play this game but anytime
you do something wrong we need to be
dynamic enough to tell you exactly what
you did wrong so you understand why
which if only I'd already written a
dialogue engine designed to handle
exactly that and since all this was
written in the same sort of ecosystem of
tooling it was trivially easy to wire up
this existing engine into the
switchboard game and so now this is
powering the switchboards tutorial as an
aside if any of you are interactive
fiction you people used to check out my
tool it's great the slides will be
available later another example so the
first time I showed it I had this
problem where often the make this old
crusty hardware having been shipped
across the country things were going
wrong I didn't know why I couldn't tell
is the hardware malfunctioning what like
why does the internal state of the game
not match the state of the physical
hardware but I already had this concept
of so this engine has like an an output
object that's essentially treating as an
event emitter that it's a vetting these
amounts of like you should turn on this
LED I also already have this iPad build
of the game that works what if I could
just broadcast to multiple outputs and
what if one of those was actually some
JavaScript blue code that connected via
WebSocket to the iPad app and all of a
sudden I had an iPad app that I could
hold and see in real time what the game
thought its internal state was and I
could fix things as need be and because
everything was in place this was maybe
half an hour of work for something like
architecture in this differently
wouldn't have wouldn't have meant oh
this is going to take longer for me to
do like categorically this wouldn't have
been a solution I would have considered
which is fantastic but so I think
everything I'm talking about like this
is this is about weird the games that
use non-traditional interfaces that
doesn't mean that they have to be things
that use embedded electronics I think
sort of anything that is a game that
operates outside of this world of like
here's a game engine and you have
characters moving around I'm like I've
done stuff like this for like web games
and party games I also worked on this
game called When in Rome this is a
tabletop game that you buy on Amazon
like a box of cardboard components
nothing electronic in there but you also
need a smart speaker like an Alexa
device and so Alexa acts a sort of the
game master for this trivia game and as
you fly around the world
you hear interview questions asked to
you by locals in the city as you're
traveling in the game and so this is all
like for those of you who haven't done
any sort of smart speaker app or skill
development this is all web tech they're
sort of a model where when you speak to
your Alexa that gets turned into an
intent which is sort of a data object
representing here is what the user wants
to do that's sent to your web server as
an HTTP request you get to do whatever
you want with it and then send back a
response that has some XML that gets
translated into text being spoken or
audio playing or whatever and if you're
doing the sort of development what can
be a little frustrating is a lot of the
official tools for Amazon or other
platforms like that is the only model
that exists there's no good way to test
your app other than deploying it or
finding a way to like get your local dev
machine on the open Internet so you can
actually talk to your Alexa device and
run through Amazon servers there's no
good way to test it locally or type on
the command line instead of having to
physically talk which is a real problem
when say you're doing this in an office
of a tech incubator where every single
company is building Alexa skills so the
result was something very similar like
we conceptually like the entire game is
a state machine and all of the intents
that you're getting in our edges to make
state machines transitions which means
that like our actual games API as it
were is a single function where you pass
in the intent you were given you pass in
some state that represents like what is
this current user session of the game
and then an output object which again
here is a nice little interface that
knows how to do like mutate able things
to the outside world and then eventually
it returns a new a new state for the
next the next run-through the next time
that user does something and so for the
production build of the game this is
just wired up inside a tiny little node
app that takes the request from Amazon
runs it through this and then that
output objects it's out XML back to
Amazon but we can also have like in
theory here's a is easy to integrate
this with any other voice UI platform
that we've launched up the game on or
more practically here is the command
line version of the game to let me test
without going to Amazon's website but so
we've gotten pretty deep into this of
like alright we're we're writing all
this code to get this Hardware working
why does this actually matter
again if my goal is to make time
management game where you're a
switchboard operator I could have
shipped the iPad version I could have
just written it in whatever I wanted and
orders of magnitude more people would
have played it and I've even heard of
this thing it really matters though like
to me what's the magic of hello operator
is when I show it at events and someone
will come up and like maybe there's
someone who plays games maybe they're
not it is clear they're probably not
someone who would ever like take their
free time and go to a telecommunications
museum but they see this thing and they
immediately go oh that I've always
wondered how that works like how does
that work and then they will sit down
and in this noisy hectic loud show floor
spend like half an hour in a deep state
of flow learning how to do someone's day
job from 90 years ago and that's super
cool like it's it's gamification but the
good kind of gamification like if it was
a little more didactic it wouldn't work
but it works because you're learning
you're learning a real-world skill which
I love designing games based on
real-world skills because you already
have this really nice skill curve like
things that people actually do in the
real world are often already designed as
good games to some extent but also you
know it's an obsolete and useless skill
like it feels like play in a way that it
wouldn't otherwise even though we are
secretly teaching you something which is
awesome and even if you don't care about
that like one layer of abstraction up
like this is kind of obvious but the way
you physically interact with something
shapes your experience of it like even
purely in software using a piece of
software that use every day on your
tablet or on your phone that feels
tangibly different from using the same
thing on your computer even within that
using like a shiny new MacBooks a
butterfly keyboard feels different than
using a nice mechanical keyboard with
nice cherry switches like as an artist
making weird experiences having that as
a dynamic range to play with is really
interesting but even given all that like
maybe maybe you're here at Strange Loop
because you're you're you're a
programmer or your heater program I
think a lot of the strains of audience
is not that but even that like if you
don't care about artistic expression as
its own ideal
doing something with physical hardware
is super interesting and useful and
teaches you a lot about what you do even
if you're just plugging some LEDs and to
an Arduino like what you learn about the
way other forms of nearing work is going
to inform your day to day work like if
you're having to do a literal smoke test
where you turn the hardware on and make
sure it doesn't light up in flames
because you saw it or something wrong
like that might impact how you think
about software testing having to deal
with spending three hours fabricating a
PCB and then having it not work like
that will give you a little more
appreciation for feedback cycles and web
devs and maybe give you a little more
discipline and we're trying to get
things to work the first time but also
above all I'm really just being selfish
like I want more weird things like this
to exist in the world like this is this
is going to talk with a bunch of
technical stuff but it is not a like
deep down technical dive I just want to
show off cool things that I have made so
that you can go be inspired and make
cool things yourself and using using
this idea of you don't have to go and
learn game development or all these
other forms of engineering you can use a
lot of the tools you already use in your
day-to-day life as a programmer and
apply those to making something weird
and cool and exciting and that's all
I've got
Thanks
[Applause]